San Francisco, California is known as the "City by the Bay".
Located on the coast of Northern California,...
...San Francisco is home to some of the most popular tourist destinations in the state.
On Alcatraz Island in San Francisco Bay,...
...you can take a tour of the legendary prison that once housed Al Capone.
During a visit to this beautiful city,...
...you can take a stroll across the Golden Gate Bridge,...
...explore the fish markets, shops, and restaurants along Fisherman's Wharf,...
...take a surprising drive down Lombard Street,...
...and be sure to take a ride on one of the city's famous cable cars.
There is so much to see and do in this lively and exciting city.